Secretary of State Mike Pompeo says he
had no idea his department's outgoing
Inspector General was investigating him
Pompeyo insists the decision on Friday
to replace Steve linic was not
retaliation lennick is one of five
internal government watchdogs to be
removed by the president since March as
Nancy Cordes reports mr. Trump says
firing linic was not his idea Mike
requested that I do it
president Trump told reporters that it
was Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who
wanted his agency's Inspector General
fired I guess they weren't happy with
the job he's doing or something now
lawmakers from both parties are asking
the president for a detailed reasoning
for the firing how Speaker Nancy Pelosi
sighting reports that linic was nearing
completion of an investigation into the
approval of billions of dollars in arms
sales to Saudi Arabia that arms sale by
declaring a fake emergency in order to
just go forward without the
accountability and transparency is
something that was worthy of attention
in an interview with The Washington Post
Secretary Pompeo said that Linux work
was undermining the State Department and
that the Obama appointee wasn't
performing a function in a way that we
had tried to get him to it's simply not
possible for this to be an act of
retaliation Pompeo said claiming that he
was unaware that linic may also have
been investigating Pompeo himself for
allegedly directing a political
appointee to run personal errands you
mean he's under investigation because he
had somebody walk his dog from the
government I don't know doesn't say I
don't think it sounds like that
important I mean President Trump says
he's happy to fire any inspector general
who was appointed by his predecessor for
CBS this morning Nancy Cordes Washington